un château de 1000 mètres carrés logé en
Vallée de Chevreuse dans un domaine de
23 hectares un tableau qui fait rêver un
lieu parfait pour accueillir aux portes
de Paris des décors d'une émission de
télé-réalité il s'agit de la Star
Academy qui a choisi le château de la
jeunesse pour son grand retour mais à
qui appartient cette demeure datant de
1850 depuis l'année dernière Isabelle
pazic en est heureuse propriétaire je
cherchais une écurie à reprendre dans la
région et j'ai une amie qui avait son
cheval donc dans ces écuries et qui
m'avait fait découvrir le domaine où il
y a au moins quatre cinq ans on s'est
dit qu'il y avait vraiment un beau
projet à faire donc au niveau équitation
et aussi on dit avec tous les le bâti
qu'il y avait quelque chose à faire il y
a donc les écuries et donc le château il
y a donc la tour
et un pavillon de dessin qui est une
petite maison qui est un petit peu sur
le haut ah bah c'est un petit peu irréel
en fin de compte parce que on arrive du
plateau de Saclay on peut arriver voir
d'une zone qui est quand même hyper
urbanisée en descend dans cette vallée
et puis on arrive dans ce
de verdure et forcément il y a forcément
un coup de cœur
bienvenue Isabelle décide de mettre en
location le château pour des tournages
après quelques clichés de mode c'est au
tour dans des mods d'investir les lieux
pour plusieurs mois fin février les
équipes de production démontront les
décors pour rendre le château fin mars
Isabelle basic a déjà quelques projets
comme l'ouverture du site au public pour
les Journées du Patrimoine
on va je dirais
commémorer les céléçons du premier saut
en parachute qui s'est fait au-dessus du
domaine de la jeunesse
pour organiser l'événement Pascal
Bouchain un habitant de Châteaufort
passionné par l'histoire de son village
il y a plusieurs châteaux un château
fort il y a le château du Gavoy il y
avait le château d'or si il y a le
château de la Geneste donc c'est vrai
qu'il y avait plusieurs propriétés
issues des anciens fiefs en 1913 le site
s'inscrit dans l'histoire grâce à
Célestin peggout un jeune aviateur
travaillant à but pour Louis Blériot
lors d'un test réalisé au-dessus du
domaine de la jeunesse le pilote
audacieux abandonne son avion en plein
vol et réussi à sauver sa vie en sautant
en parachute le parachute s'est ouvert
en plein vol et à arraché son le pilote
de son avion et l'avion
s'est retrouvé seul à 250 mètres
d'altitude au lieu de tomber bêtement il
est remonté à la verticale il a décroché
sur la queue il est remonté une seconde
fois un petit peu comme un avion en
papier l'avion aurait accompli un
looping et c'est ainsi qu'un nez la
voltige aérienne et oui à château fort
de la chanson à l'aviation il n'y a
qu'un pas mais du coup il a développé